guys why was it important for you to be
here and how does it feel being back
together
well it always feels like family
it always feels like a reunion it always
feels like
we're about to laugh really hard for the
next 48 hours
which we do we do yeah well describe
that tight-knit bond that you guys have
had for so long and it just keeps
getting stronger
um
god we've been friends for so long for
decades it's crazy
we really are like family at this point
if people try to eavesdrop on our
conversations they won't understand it
because there's so many inside jokes we
have our own dialogues yeah our own
dialects speak in code
okay so are there group chats are there
holidays spent together
talk about what happens off camera
we can't talk about the stuff that
happens off camera
yes it's very immature
and uh
you know like andrea said there's so
many little inside bits that we've
collected over the years
you know it you can't really
put this kind of chemistry together
intentionally it either happens or it
doesn't
and we just you know we've remained
family through
everything all these years it's been
right now is it because i'm talking
serious right now that that that's what
throws you off it's strange because
bob's not here so you're allowed to talk
you can't
always hog the conversation that is true
that is true
now you can get a word now we all get to
talk my sweet friend dave dave plays
joey on the show pretty much eats all
the time now over here mayo and then he
used to live it's kind of mustard though
oh look at this we got a one-eyed freak
here
but it is so it is odd not having bob
here though and he is such a big piece
and heart of this family
how are you guys doing
with his loss
it's been really tough it's been really
difficult i think for all of us in in
different ways i met bob when i was 18
years old
and
you know i i knew the bob before he was
famous full house bob and so i i share
all those memories but together us
as a family have so many funny amazing
memories that will
carry us through the rest of our lives
and talk about inappropriate i saw his
stand-up act a couple of times he was
hilarious he was so funny
i think that's why this
coming together to do this conference
this weekend was important to us because
it was just a way for us to spend time
together we're excited to meet everyone
and meet the fans but we just we wanted
a good bonding weekend because uh it it
helps through it helps the process
through the grief there was so much
outpouring of love from people all over
the world what was it about bob what was
it about his portrayal of danny tanner
that you think really impacted people so
so much i think it was his warmth i
think that with all of his
humor and his famously inappropriate
humor he was really just he had a huge
heart and um and it everybody could you
know we could you know people who knew
him well felt it but the whole world you
just you know the whole world sensed it
and felt it he was you know it's funny
this whole america's dad he really was
and um
and and he connected all of us he was
always texting all of us and and i would
get mad at him i would say bob you're
always on your phone and now i know why
yeah because he was always texting us
and calling us and checking in and
you know he was always there for all of
us he would always check are you okay
you know um
you know i know gas prices are going up
but are you okay
you know i mean he was
you know he was
really uh the connective tissue between
all of us he was the glue yeah so who's
the glue moving forward who will who
will i'm the gluten
that holds us together it's true so
i just ate a loaf of bread over there
before we started the interview so i
feel great
it's weird bob still is the glue like i
think we all like feel like we've got to
keep it going keep you know the
relationship strong yeah because you
know it just feels like he he sort of
brought us back together in a way he's
stronger than ever and i will carry on
the inappropriate torch perfect and i
will carry on
the leadership in a danny tanner super
organized in front of everything she's
already charged kind of way and i'm
gonna keep up the deeply neurotic jewish
guy
perfect perfect
i feel like he should be sitting right
there it's just you know it just
he's here in spirit don't you feel that
i'm talking about him a lot yeah yeah he
was in my room all night
and i just said bob with the spirit
thing stop it enough bob enough
flying around hey are you okay about gas
prices you all right
stop it i need to sleep